think about if so many legends have
graced the Apollo stage Ella Fitzgerald
Jimi Hendrix James Brown that's amazing
yeah tonight I can almost hear their
ghost saying who let that white woman on
stage
what do people like it when I'm sad
after it yeah I got some big political
news you know this president Trump's
approval rating among African Americans
is now at 4% 4% yeah yeah yeah I know
what you're thinking when did it go up
it's I don't like it things not going
too well for Trump yeah this week a
federal judge banned his former campaign
manager Paul Manafort from leaving the
country he can't leave the country yeah
true story yes so now if Manta Ford
wants to meet with Russians he'll be
forced to go to any nightclub in
Manhattan I didn't need to get sad after
that one I love being uptown but I've
noticed there's a lot of gentrification
in Harlem a lot of gentrification yeah
in fact it's gotten so bad the Harlem
Globetrotters and now a bunch of white
guys who play hockey and they're good
they're very good I always love going to
shows when I'm here in New York you like
Broadway shows or the best I love them
there's a Broadway revival of Hello
Dolly yeah very cool it's an updated
version called you up Dee
[Applause]
that's a little harder to sing yeah yeah
doesn't really don't work I can't tell
you how much I miss this city since I
moved to Los Angeles
I'm beyond the day yeah it's different
it's really different there in Los
Angeles I had to hire someone to tell me
to go myself
he does it he'll do it yeah yeah
I just said you'd do it for free that's
all that's the great thing about New
York you have to worry about that
you